is Machado a Padre officially or not
Chris Braman not officially that's the
report that he's signed a ten-year 300
million dollar contract although Padres
executives saying not exactly a done
deal so we're still kind of waiting
official official word okay I'm looking
online right here and it looks like the
terms and the dollars are official but
not the no trade clause
I also saw reports of an opt-out after
year 5 so he can get paid again in five
years from now all right no I think
they're just trying to iron out the you
know the efficient well we figured with
the it looking like Machado is gonna be
a Padraig we call the only Padre family
know anyone and that's my my friend
compadre NFL Media Group colleague with
whom I'll be spending an absurd amount
of time at the combine next week Daniel
Jeremiah DJ either I am I'm here rich
and Kevin AC who knows all things Padres
that said everything is done it's just a
physical and supplying which details but
it but I feel good I feel good that it's
done you're feeling good okay Kevin AC
who works for for The Times Union down
there right in San Diego okay Union
Tribune pardon me so okay so how you
feeling about this DJ you must be out of
your mind right now to two things two
things a really excited just don't have
a lot of superstar players haven't
really had one you know going back to
Tony Grant and Trevor Hoffman so to have
a superstar as exciting
the downside is I had given my only
Padres hat to my fifteen-year-old son a
couple years ago and I went and
retrieved it and stole it from his room
today and apparently those fitted hats
really kind of shrink to your head so I
have a splitting headache after trying
to wear that also your stars rising at
the NFL Network so clearly your hat size
has gotten bigger with each passing
assignment so I mean again isn't it
amazing
I said this before what would the odds
have been at some point in the last 30
years if you could make a bet put even a
singular dollar American dollar on a bet
that the San Diego Padres would hand out
the richest contract in the history of
American sports it's crazy how about
that how about that well the thing is
that I saw that somewhere I still think
they're below like the MLB average you
know for payroll I don't think they're
even on top half in terms of payroll
they have so many young guys the
baseball system is so different the
football system I mean we always talk
about you know winning with with rookie
quarterbacks on that rookie deal maybe
baseball players yeah the payoff you
know when you get to this point is huge
but for those first couple years they
don't make anything so when you have a
bunch of young players you can keep your
payroll pretty low and you can support a
couple a couple these big numbers and if
you need somebody in the outfield with
speed and a little bit of pop maybe you
can go ahead and trade for Kyler Murray
after he uses that to his advantage
against a team that grabs him but he
doesn't want to go too right DJ by the
way if he I mean we talked about this I
think a little bit earlier maybe a week
or so ago but doesn't he still have that
power to kind of determine which NFL
team but I mean he's come out and he's
did what we thought he had to do DJ
which is at least I thought he had to he
had to declare before going to the
combine one sport or another that he
could not go into these meeting rooms in
the way that he went on my show on Dan
Patrick show at the Super Bowl saying
you know hey I'll let you know when I
know I mean he had to let you know that
but I mean what team is you know what
team would draft him that he doesn't
want to go to that he says I'm gonna go
play baseball I don't I mean I don't I
don't know which team that would be
right I mean I guess in that respect
before I let you go which team are you
hearing right now that would actually
have interested in this kid well I mean
look it's all just a lot of rumor and
talking to people around the league it's
speculating not from the team's
themselves that tell you hey that's
that's our guy we're interested but the
names just talk buddies around the
league that comes up over and over again
is Jacksonville and I think that one
does make sense in terms of you know
they're gonna be you know get healthy on
the offensive line the defense I think
will bounce back they can run the ball
play-action which gives you a deeper
pocket we said that about Russell Wilson
he was coming out you know having a run
heavy team is gonna allow you to play
action which you set deeper in the
pocket you could be really clear back
there and then you have somebody that
can generate four or five explosive
plays if their defense is back to where
they should be that's all you're really
going to need there so
that's the team that keeps popping up
over and over again and I think that one
does make a lot of sense at seven huh
and that would be after Haskins goes to
the Giants unless somebody somebody
might hop pop up into the top five I
mean cuz all the mock drafts I'm seeing
have only defensive lineman pretty much
being taken in the top five right now
see I snuck a conversation in on your
right now it's not a dragon no we should
by the way we should hang up right now
rich and we got hours and hours no okay
but you but so that you're gonna save
the gold instead of going on the NFL
Network mike Mayock three and a half
hour marathon press conference right I
mean have you got have you I know what
are you gonna do here on that next
Monday I know what I you know we talked
the other day in and I thought you had a
great idea which is say this is a new
era you know this this media friendly
accessible you know mike Mayock saying
is the thing of the past this is a lot
done you know i get one when we know it
give Jim Hill gets the first question
right all right DJ okay I guess congrats
on Machado in advance all right and I
hope it doesn't blow up on you and we
thanks for being the only Padre fan we
know I gotta go get a new hat yeah
definitely size it resize it alright DJ
I'll see you an indie well I think
you're coming on next week before so
well can't wait that's Daniel Jeremiah
will be sitting next to him at the
combine coverage the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience